ruskin if you are missing the team at
Cole Arriba advertising agency are on
the hunt for a new fragrance they
branched out into producing their own
series of cosmetics and have already had
success their branding is aimed at the
environmentally aware consumer their
slogan stop the water while using me
yeah it doesn't go and kick as well
samaha it gives me a bigger kick than
buying a big car for example we're
entrepreneurs and we invest our money
and new ideas we preach to our customers
every day about what they should do so
it's good to prove that we can do it too
and can you yeah amazingly yes or not
amazingly yes we can do it too the
advertising agency is based in hamburg's
warehouse district it's above snappy
texts and campaigns still make up most
of the business but the job description
has altered slightly not only have they
recently become manufacturers of a range
of cosmetics they also offer product
management services to customers
has been kunda tuan's compns out here
the client might say they have a peach
and plum flavored yogurt that they want
to bring out at Christmas and we tell
them there are already 30 identical
flavored yogurts and wouldn't be better
to think about it we really talked to
our clients about products and product
development in response to their clients
needs Stefan Cola and his team have
already helped develop beer biscuits and
energy drinks over the past few years
for its very own product the advertising
agency is enlisting the help of a
special natural cosmetics laboratory on
the other side of Hamburg doctors
treatments has been working with natural
materials for more than 30 years and is
commissioned by the world's biggest
brands all of us Olivia Fernando avarra
the head of technical marketing at dr.
statements wasn't surprised when an
advertising agency came knocking at his
door he fun te de Chaumont I thought it
was a very charming idea and I wouldn't
have taken it on if I didn't believe in
it India far one goes to cosmetic nose
but you have to be able to position
yourself and because we work with so
many similar projects we know it could
be a thorny path to begin with reactive
ignite nvidia does dustin good least I
[ __ ] VX ein con Stefan Cola always
visits the lab himself when new recipes
are being developed there are no
chemicals and no frills I'm getting
kingsandems rather than under life to
attend it's also buddies in the other
side by Google Disney life the final
touch is the branding splashed over the
packaging the cosmetics range is selling
well internationally despite not being
promoted by big advertising campaigns
and turnover is growing after just two
years on the market
his product up this product has won more
prizes than any other cosmetic product
in the world over the last two years
which meant it started appearing in
design blogs lifestyle blogs environment
and eco blogs who blocks until I don't
apply to teach those phones 8 when
dozens kindly it's spread by itself
which is the most modern form of
communication for biotin the agency is
developing the cosmetics range at the
same time as conducting business as
usual but it's becoming ever more
important to Stefan Cola his aim is to
create and market a new brand every 15
months